[Music]
what a fam
it's me four salons welcome to a new
video I'm so excited for those of you
that don't know me I'm Grace's cousin
and um um and she wanted me to step in
because she knows that I guess I mean I
don't know kind of like good with girls
she thought it'd be cool if I give you
some advice for Valentine's Day about
relationships and just um hooking up you
guys have some questions on Twitter so I
thought it'd be cool to just get into a
here we go um poor we get into these
questions I want to say that I love you
guys so much I like like seriously like
I love I love you like I would assure
all of you um not the ugly ones like I
think so much of your support and like I
love you and I love the hot ones that
follow me on social media do lips get
chapped from licking them so much no but
they get chapped from you licking them
so much because you use your tongue boom
we kiss we kiss
that's a lyric from my new single that's
coming out uh-huh I'm gonna follow me on
grant which Axe body spray scent helps
me get all the [ __ ] there's no limit
to the amount of Axe body spray that you
should put on yourself
it's literally like honey to bees and oh
the bees actually produced honey and not
necessarily attracted to honey but like
my body's so hot it's like I produce
acts I don't sweat exa ohh
which sports team you don't actually
fall snapback is most appropriate for
the occasion Furillo
I don't think that you should wear
snapback on Valentine's Day I think it's
really disrespectful on today it's all
about her survivors respect kiss you
[ __ ]
straight out man what does your amount
of privilege feel like a lot of people
say it feels really good I ain't got no
complaints privileges comment
how many Valentine's Day dates is too
many lot of is infinite God isn't
goddess love God made [ __ ] infinite
[ __ ] Valentine's Day are your parents
proud
they're American would you rather a
jellyfish or a Portuguese man-of-war and
do it I'm not gay but I totally support
gay arm so I probably a man punch the
jellyfish but that's just me how do you
have the self-confidence to talk to
people I don't talk to people I don't
have people how many licks does it take
to get to the center of a Tootsie Roll
pop mine takes me one I am the center of
the 2-stroke but you may have to pull
out you gotta put it in also equip no
you should follow me on snapchat cuz I'm
doing a lot of like selfies um with
different filters and I'm it's way
different how do you ask if she's on the
pill more flirty way I'll mess with
chicks at do drugs God one love how easy
is it to break someone's heart I don't
break hearts and make hearts it's a fake
hard to take hearts at fart farts that
might have been another sneak peek of my
new single check me on Graham do you
feel like nagging a girl is a foolproof
way to get her to be into you
no offense um but I'm pretty sure you're
that super racist so I'm not I'm not
racist do you own a belt no but one day
I'd like to own an island girl what's
the best way to get a boy's attention
from always focused
unlike a camera with automatic focus
it's all about you unless there's a
hotter girl to your direct right or left
then why do you flirt with me and then
claim to be straight I don't flirt I
just live I'm not straight what's your
favorite Nickelback song and get it on -
I don't like Nickelback I like
quarterback Tom Brady wanna come back a
chicken what's your favorite part about
tinder that allows me to socially hide
the fact that I use Grindr on a regular
basis what is your mouth a pious
pleasure and being a jerk to my friends
I jerk off like twice a day can you
actually be romantic I can do whatever
you want me to be girl I am be your boy
I can be with boy why your dick so small
lots of dudes know what was it bro
should i buy condoms or you think she
let me do her without using one you only
need condoms dudes is it gay if you let
her lick your butt I'm gay all right
guys that's all for this Twitter
valentine's day Q&A i hope this helped
you with your romantic situations I hope
you find what you're looking for
once again my name is parks lawns -
cheese threesies don't forget to follow
me on social media cuz I post some fire
[ __ ] there um and I'll see you guys next
time
just remember I'm super gay
pause for a quick second just saying
thank you guys for all your love and
your support
I'd like I love you like I truly truly
love you in just the most superficial
way I love you and I also love saying
things that I don't really mean but
there's this generic sentiment about
everything I do and I have to maintain
it because I just I have no idea who I
am or what I'm doing I've never felt
real feelings before basically an
evolved version of a piece of cardboard
and I love you and it thank you for all
your support I couldn't be here without
you God